right yeah I'm working with dtec um we
where we buil an open source framework
for running GPU workloads and all kind
of gen workloads as well including
llms um and today I'll be talking about
open source llms and how to tweak them
for production this is going to be a
pretty introductionary level so if you
are an expert in Al LS probably you'll
not learn
much but still we'll see uh but if if
you are um a beginner or intermediate
level and basically curious about um
what are these um well important
questions around around using uh llms
and production that that might be a
great fit um and um let's let's see how
it goes
right first question which we're going
to talk about today is why using open
source LMS anyway um well we we all know
um about chat GPT and proprietar LMS and
I bet that um most of you actually had
some experience with this um um I also
put um small poll um which you can find
uh on the right hand side and and uh
vote uh uh what what what level of
experience you have with open source LM
so we're going to we're going to see in
the end of the presentation but for now
let's um let's start with a question of
why to use open source
LMS given that there are proprietary
models so there are four fundamental
reasons first reason is uh control um
and this is something that people talk a
lot today um when you're using a propar
model you don't have much control of the
behavior of the model and if the Model
Behavior changes from a release to
release um your business might be at
risk and your application might stop
working um there is also risk of that
particular provider might change
something
um um how they offer that model and of
course open source LMS have have a lot
more uh
control basically if you own the weights
of your model you can decide how they
are served and how exactly they are
integrated into your apps so it starts
with owning your weights and this is why
open source LMS is a big thing because
weights are well not yours but they
almost yours they they are they are open
um and you can use them without any
restrictions then customization is a big
thing and this is why uh there are very
well uh popular models which we'll talk
about uh in the fur the
slides opens open weight open weights
llm are great because you can build on
top of them if a company uh open open
releases open weights of the model other
company can build on top of this um and
reuse the approach uh that
llm um used or use a custom data set and
tailor their model for a
specific use case so basically it's all
about community and you can very easily
build on top of Open Source LM
then there are two other um factors one
is cost which is
a difficult topic to to talk because
there are so many dimensions um but
there are
certainly cases when you can
significantly reduce costs of using llms
if you are using open source llms this
is typically done by using a smaller
model um also leveraging badge inference
um and also increasing the quality of
the model by leveraging fine-tuning and
all sorts of
customizations and finally of course
privacy is a big topic and again this is
a separate thing to to talk about um
every company has
different um expectations in terms of
the privacy and um to a certain extent
there is no problem with using open Ai
and similar
Services when it comes to pricing
privacy but of course when you're using
open source zelms you have entire
control you decide how data is processed
um and you can be sure that there is no
privacy issue there um
right
the the next slide is is about major
open source LMS and by no chance um I
aim to talk about all their major
releases of llms it's just not phys
physically possible to mention all of
them um within this talk but I would
just mention several which are which
probably you're already aware of uh
and those that you really have to know
first is of course LMA 2 Lama 2 is a
model by meta which is offered in
partnership with Microsoft and this is
probably the most popular open- Source
model um and it is offered in three
different
sizes 7B
30 13 billion parameters and 70 billion
parameters um this uh this means um how
large is the model how many parameters
are in the model um but you can think of
this as a size of the model and the
larger the model the better the quality
is um then it's worth to mention that
llama is offer it not just in three
different sizes but also in two
different flavors let's say first one is
a base model means that this model can
com complete text generate text and
there's also a version that is
fine-tuned for following instructions or
[Music]
um um having
conversations um also known as chat
model so Lama is offered in into this uh
formats then and well to mention about
too this is this was their um their in
terms of quality one of the best models
and it comes with a license that allows
to use this model commercially um so
this is why there was so much Buzz about
Lama the motel is really great it's very
customizable and it can be used
commercially without restrictions or
without almost without
restrictions another model to mention is
code Lama this is basically
another model by meta which is a
fine-tuned version of Lama but it it was
fine-tuned for generating code um which
is a big thing and a totally separate
use case very important for for us why
um mainly well when when when you're
working with llm it it can um generate
um
human content but if you are using
something like code Lama it can generate
code and then it means that you can
automate the execution of that code for
example think of two use cases one use
case is you can generate cql code and
automate the access to your data uh on
of the model um which which is a very
powerful use case another one is
generating for example Json and Json
means that you can generate API calls
means that you can automate accessing
third party services on behalf of the
llm um which which is a entirely
different level of
automation code Lama can not only
complete code it can also um well change
the the code in the in the middle uh the
technique known as mid fill in the
middle and it's also offered in three
different sizes though the largest mot
is not 70 billion but half of the size
and the third one in our list is Mistral
Mistral is relatively new model is is um
it is released by The M company and what
is great about mistal is that it's one
of the most capable smallest model so it
it's only offered in the 7 billion
perometer size but it outperforms um all
of the model the same
size and even uh some of the model of
their um of their largest size like 13
billion
perameters here's here's a slide with
some Benchmark data it is from the
original paper of of Lama 2 where it
Compares Lama 2 to some other models um
and what we see here on the left hand
side is the list of different benchmarks
Benchmark is basically something that
measures how model behaves um in terms
of quality on a specific task first one
is
MMO uh massive multil language
understanding just simply tells how how
would the model overall on across
different
tasks and um what is what is worth
attention here is that lama lama 2 comes
really close in terms of quality to GPT
3.5 um which you might be um familiar
with um and at the same time you can
also see that Lama 2 um falls behind
significantly uh GPT behind GPT 4 so
basically basically it's it's almost
good as GPT 3.5 but it's not as good as
GPT 4 like significantly which is no
surprise because ler 70 billion
parameters so GPT 3.5 is 135 billion
parameters like more than uh more than
twice bigger and GPT 4 is 10 times
bigger than GPT 3.5 um which is amazing
difference but still you see that open
source LM can can well come really close
in terms ofquality to proper are LS
right um here is another Benchmark data
now about Mistral um and um basically
what what this this Benchmark data shows
is that mad um across various benchmarks
uh bits uh models of the same size and
it also bits uh quite a few models of
their twice bigger size uh which is just
another way to say that Mr Al is a super
um efficient small model uh and no
surprise why Mr is used um when it comes
to working with um small models Mr is
also very customizable and it beats a
llama um in quality when it comes to the
to the size of small
models right um here's here's an example
uh here's some data from
Snowflake um where they took um Lama 2
of different sizes and then they
fine-tune this model for a very specific
problem in this case generating SQL
queries and what they learned is that
just by fine tuning even a very small
model you can achieve a quality of
um let's say the largest one or even
come really close to GPT 4 so here you
see that the F un verion of Lama 2 7
billion parameters came almost um to the
same accuracy as Cod Lam 30 34 billion
parameters and not that much far from
GPT
4 um this is
another um Benchmark data showing now
wizard coder and find um models which
are fine tune version of Lama where they
um basically um aimed at beating GPT for
uh when it comes to code generation
there's a funny story about how this
went out basically uh G pt4 back then
when they worked on this model was not
that good on code generation and they
basically proved that it is possible to
find tune Lama 2 to be much better than
GPT 4 well what happened um uh in the
following weeks that open AI basically
updated the model and as you see here on
the slide GPT 4 is still the best when
it comes to code
generation but also um to mention that
it is possible to find tun Lama or well
uh if there will be other open source
models
uh to match the equality of GPT for for
code
Generation Um so let's talk about some
economic uh
economics um on like
coost and here's a here's a screenshot
of um of an app um which you can also
find on hugging face spasis which um if
you give uh it a name of a model it
automatically calculates how much memory
you would need in order to run inference
or training with that model so here if
we take the largest Lama 2 model 70
billion parameter that then you'll see
if we take the original their full
Precision basically if we take their
weights in the in the in the full
Precision you know that weights are fla
Point numbers and the full Precision is
uh is what um like um is this fla. 32 um
you would you would
need
256 gigabytes of memory just in order to
run inference with that model uh which
which means that it's not even possible
to fit this uh model into one single GPU
and this is a big problem now if you
look at training um using for example
the standard um um Adam
um algorithm then um it's it's not
possible to to fit uh into a GPU uh by
no means it's it would need one terabyte
of data but in the further slides we'll
we'll see how we what we can do about it
to to to make it easier uh before we do
that um here's here's the
slide um showing the study by hugging
phas done together with AWS what they
did um they they they took uh three
different sizes of Lama 2 and then they
tried to run inference there and then
they measured latency and costed per
token and per million of tokens
and what you can see here for example
the last row if you take Lama to 70
billion parameters you would you would
actually need uh the largest AWS
instance that they can offer one that
the most expensive one one that has
eight gpus of uh a100 uh each 100
gigabytes and then uh
for one request uh sorry for one token
you would need 41
milliseconds and with just one
concurrent request which is just a way
to say that it's not really fast in
terms of the latency and here on the
right hand side if if you look at the
cost you'll see that basically in order
to generate one million of tokens which
is well not that much but you would need
basically 500 not sorry
4227 which which is a way to say that
it's pretty expensive and pretty
difficult to run inference with an open
well with with any model but uh even
with open source model um so now we'll
talk about some some B basic very basic
techniques that um allow us to reduce
the requirements and make it easier to
to use LMS first one is quantization so
if if you know as you know um an llm is
basically a set of Weights um uh which
are just fla Point numbers and most most
common way to represent them is through
float Point 16 um um and it's called
also as half Precision um and even
though it's half Precision it's still a
lot of memory needed in order to for
both for inference and for training so
that that's why um there is such a
technique called
quantization and it works uh the
following way you convert uh the weights
from the float Point uh 16 former into
for example in 8 or in 4 format which is
just another way to say that you lower
the rank uh lower the the Precision and
change um uh the way these ways are
represented but by doing this uh the
best thing about this is that you can do
this um with very little drop in quality
um and this is a very big thing because
now by by lowering the Precision uh you
improve the latency basically the time
you reduce the time needed for inference
and for training you need you reduce the
amount of energy needed for that so it
it is very helpful in many ways so now
if we look at the same memory calculator
we we see that um if we reduce the the
uh the rank um we also reduce um
linearly the
memory required for inference and for
train training for example if you are
using the largest Lama model and if you
for example take int 8 um Precision um
then it will be 64 gabt only for
inference means that you now can fit it
into one GPU um and if you don't have
that um expensive GPU you can go even
lower precision and for example um um
yeah use int for uh quantization and it
will fit in into um into 40 gab GPU same
with training so by using the
quantization technique you significantly
drop the amount of memory
required for for training but then it
still won't fit into one single GPU but
you will be um able to use multiple gpus
for that or multiple notes with multiple
gpus um so this is powerful technique so
now the same slide um but now Now with
uh with a
quantization used here so we we see that
for example by by leveraging the
quantization we can drop significantly
their cost to generate one million of
token like almost 10 times to 60 dollars
per one million um
right um another technique which is very
important to know and understand how it
works is is called Laura uh which stands
for low rank adaptation um the biggest
problem with LMS is that they are very
large and they don't Feit GPU memory um
so this technique allows us to to froze
the weights of the model um and take
take only a smaller subset of these
weights which we'll call adap an adapter
and then we'll only load this adapter
much smaller adapter into the GPU memory
and then we'll use that that for
training and then we will train that
adapter um without the needs to load all
the way into their uh GPU memory and
then once we've trained that adapter
we'll merge that adapter with a frozen
uh rest of the model uh to get the final
model um this is a powerful technique
because it it allows you significantly
reduce the amount of memory required for
training um
and um the best part is that the quality
drop is not that significant which and
there is a lot of U research body body
of research showing that it's pretty
efficient technique um it's just here's
just an example for example if you take
Falcon uh 180 billion parameters the
largest ever open source model that
exists um you see um how the
requirements for of like memory
requirements changes
um for training so if if you are just
using their full precision and without
any techniques it would require you it
would require from you five uh petabytes
of memory GPU memory uh which is just um
um too much and by using Laura and then
using quantization you can drop this
requirements like a not of magnitude
basically for example if you combine
quantization and Laura
it will be 160 gigabytes uh which makes
it very efficient um if you decides to
to f tune um such a model here's here's
a study that that proves that uh this
one is published by any scale they
basically took Lama uh three different
sizes and they fine-tuned this model on
three
different data sets problems one is for
extracting structure data in another
code generation and then finally solving
math problems and what they figured out
is that for certain problems such as
extracting unstructured data and code
generation it is possible to use um
Laura for fine tuning to match the
quality of the largest
model like the largest model um Lama and
also match the
they come really close to the quality of
GPT 4 or in some cases exceed the
quality of GPT 4 for example here the
first one we basically exceeded the
quality of GPT 4 um significantly just
by fine tuning a very small version
actually using Laura
here um a few more um techniques to
mention here before we conclude um if
you um if if you decide to to fine tune
in open source Elms it is worth to know
these techniques first one is called
supervised fine tuning this is the
simplest way to find tune and llm um
basically
um you take a base model a model which
was trained previously on low quality
data for example Lama 2 base model is is
a model which you take then you would
find unit by giving it high quality data
for example if you'd like to find unit
to generate um SQL queries you would
need to prepare a data set um that uh
has a prompt and generated code uh and
you basically find you your
mod uh by using this data set um you
don't need to label any anything you
just need to prepare
answers um um means that you would need
um um some people that that would work
on this data set but we'll also mention
synthetic data if we if time allows us
this is the most simple way to to fine
tune a model um however there is even
more advanced technique for example if
you are doing supervised fine tuning
like here then you only tell uh your
model what is good so basically you give
it uh a data set consisent of many
examples what is good so this is how you
teach the model to provide this good um
outcome how
however it's not enough if you'd like
the model to follow instructions or to
be aligned on certain um on certain
criteria and this is where reinforcement
learning is used also known as
rhf where you not only give it what is
good teach it what is good but also what
is bad basically you um annotate your
data set with labels like for example
good or bad or for for example a flood
Point number representing like from
from0 to 10 representing how good or bad
that particular piece of um of data of
of prompt and um
response uh and RL work RL CHF works the
way that you first use this data set to
fune an intermediate model code also
known as reward model uh so this model
learns like this this scoring and then
finally you take that uh your your
supervis your model which which you
trained before and then find unit using
the reward model so basically there are
two stages um and that that's how you
teach the motel to follow instructions
to how to reason at all so this is a one
of the most basically powerful technique
for um teaching uh an llm to to to
follow
instructions um finally um there is
another technique called
dpu which is much simpler version of our
lhf uh which doesn't use uh
reinforcement learning so um it works
pretty much same way means that you
would prepare a data set and label it
but uh it can um fine tune uh your base
model without using reinforcement
learning there is a paper on DPO and how
it different from llf so I would
recommend everyone to to read this paper
this is a very powerful technique um and
this is some study by hugging phas where
they show how DPO can Compares with rlf
in terms of their ease and quality so
basically they took Mile and
um fine-tuned it with DPO to prove that
it is possible to use DP to find youe
even a smaller model to match the
quality of a larger model so they they
show that uh DP is is quite
powerful right um so trying to conclude
here um uh by no
chance uh my talk aimed at uh well um
talking about all all important stuff
there are so so much stuff but uh there
are three topics which I would um
recommend for everyone to to take a look
at one is serving multiple luras um I
already told you about what Laura is low
low rank
adaptation um and there is a way to use
Laura not only for f uning but also for
serving multiple models and um uh making
it possible to fit many models into one
GPU uh second is uh called speculative
decoding this is how you significantly
can improve latency there there is also
a paper about this and um a lot of um a
lot of um well studies um and finally
generating synthetic data set so one of
the bottlenecks when it comes to LMS is
data sets uh you need human labor in
order to uh collect data uh curate data
and label data and it is possible to use
alms um to help with that um and there's
a lot of things you can do there to to
reduce basically the amount of human
labor needed for for creating high
quality data
sets finally uh a shameful plug here um
as I'm working with this deck um I would
just um
um encourage everyone to to take a look
this dech is an open source tool that
allows you to use any other open source
tools like PA TRL TGI VM and others for
training and for deployment and it also
allows you to to use this all all these
tools with any Cloud uh so it's just a
very
flexible way of running any kind of
workloads from fine-tuning to deployment
and Dev environments while um using any
Cloud GPU provider of your choice